yeah welcome a new video five-minute
blitz against Johan debacle at least the
sky got the German flag so probably
country mate is the word of mine so we
got the names oh and the Queen c2 line
I'm studying this at the moment so let's
try out this as variations Zurich Zurich
variation gap you prefer there should be
two and long castling again isn't this
weird I got some guy castling long on me
in this line now just a very short while
ago and castling long is really a really
direct okay yeah this has said it has
got some point to it and this is the age
6 move yeah he's going for it g 4g five
so very very direct fashion okay i need
to open up the queenside i had a game
really just a lot not quite sure maybe
like 10 or 15 games ago he and in the
youtube history where some guy also
canceled long exactly the same line okay
on GF i still can play this move and
stop them advance at least for a moment
i mean it's a it's clear that damn white
has got some serious ideas but this so
stops
thanks for a moment okay i want to i
want to go to see 5 i'm gambling that
he's not taking a five probably this
isn't so bad even but it's not the move
you want to play in the middle of your
attacking preparations okay so night
here I don't think that g5 is some yeah
it wasn't so dangerous at them at the
moment and now I was I was really
intending to play g5 myself maybe I'm is
this is insane but maybe it's baby it's
play over now if I allow him to play g5
right so it's probably terrible so let's
block it yeah lightings or pawn takes
Knight takes look stupid maybe it's
better than it now but the night on h7
isn't exactly great also ok let's take
wow this isn't exactly an aesthetic kind
of position the night on age 7 ok if I
would have some little bit of time here
in this position ok he gives me the time
to at least play f6a a little bit of
time to consolidate then maybe this
isn't so bad even from a structural
point of view this position is ok I mean
I've got all pawns on dark squares I've
got a light squared Bishop so it's um
it's not so bad in the long run but the
king
and the hulking side yeah okay so he
wants to play against Bishop to d7 I
guess my ideas to plain night to f8
night to g6 the bishop on sea otter has
one useful rowlett just a text the Jeep
on okay he's intending Nazi for it seems
yeah okay cannot too much I forgot night
c4 also a text the a porn oh this is so
this is a problem but it doesn't really
go for that
yeah my intention was to go on right age
for this just special be one yeah this
is really bad okay it's not it's nothing
threatening at the at the moment
actually tween age 60 Queen 86 is a
threat tonight edge form should be one
okay whatever I need to play some move
oh this is good well played Bishop age
seven takes on takes on now yeah just
takes on g6 over the screen h8 just
queen edge edge
yeah this is made right okay resigns
yeah I was nicely outplayed here I
thought I mean maybe around here it
isn't it isn't so terrible but lettuce
this was I need to play Bishop d7 Foley
him after after you got the night to see
for its really a la but it's really
terrible especially this five move on
backfires I played should be 78 sites
probably yeah probably still all right
self a brief LOC takes takes yeah this
is bliss is probably okay I'm quick
enough to to UM to defend the King side
and that I have some play would be five
on my own I suspected that this isn't so
terrible for me but I played I played
badly after the light was on CY to us a
night light me up yeah alright thanks
for watching and don't play the opening
like that or at least after that